the establishment has no clothes
that's the focus of tonight's angle
the collapse of afghan afghanistan
represents another catastrophic failure
of our political establishment now other
obvious examples include the collapse of
our southern border and long before that
the collapse of our once unrivaled
manufacturing base
well they keep doubling down though on
failure don't they insisting that if
they have just a few more years they can
make americans understand why their
actions why their policies are smart and
proper
and of course to distract the public
from their own abject failures these old
hacks do their best to stir up phony
crises
is there influence by the russians over
president trump his behavior hasn't done
much at least in my mind to allay that
concern maybe it's my my warning
training as an intelligence professional
i have seen the lights blinking red in
terms of what mr trump has done and is
doing and is bringing this country down
on the global stage
oh my god i can't even watch those two
and if the russians weren't going to
destabilize america they wanted you to
believe the fur and face paint
contingent would
i want to understand white rage and i'm
white and i want to understand it so
what is it that caused thousands of
people to assault this building and try
to overturn the constitution of the
united states of america what caused
that i want to find that out also
tackling the problem of violent
extremism
in our work in our ranks in our
workforce
maybe they should focus on the
extremists or the thousands of people at
the airport maybe that'd be a
how embarrassing
can you imagine what china must be
thinking
taking taiwan is going to be like taking
candy from a baby at this point
of course it's far easier isn't it to
demonize your fellow americans though
then finally own up to the fact that you
and your fellow generals spectacularly
failed in afghanistan that you didn't
own up to the obvious inadequacies of
the afghan army that you literally got
almost nothing right in this mission
right up until the end
the afghan security forces
have the capacity
to sufficiently fight
and defend their country a negative
outcome a taliban automatic military
takeover is not a foregone conclusion
golly he's so smart
and for more than 10 years before that
they sold americans false hope
the afghans are resolved
to win this fight we see success
and that convinces me that we can apply
that success across the country afghan
security forces are now on track to meet
their targeted and strength objectives
by the end of the year as we are seeing
early progress as we get the inputs
right in that country they're probably
the best trained the best equipped and
the best led of any forces we've
developed yet inside of afghanistan they
only continue to get better with time
does that not want takes your breath
away now the taliban is the best
equipped right well it was all garbage
and a new book by the washington post
craig whitlock reveals that everyone on
the ground
seemed to know it was garbage
in oral histories of the war provided to
the author
they're brutally frank assessments of
the effort to train afghan forces
the afghans suffered from a lack of
motivation and a corrupt chain of
command that preyed upon its own
soldiers and police one afghan battalion
commander whom the u.s army infantry
officer mentored lost his job after he
was charged with raping one of his male
soldiers
the commander's replacement in turn was
killed by his own men
a major problem was literacy whitlock
reports our military had to teach
virtually every afghan recruit how to
read
one officer said they couldn't even
count and some even needed to learn
their colors
yet the generals never wanted to leave
effectively treating our troops and our
tax dollars as expendable in order to
paper over their own monumental failure
of course trump a pragmatic economic
nationalist at heart
he saw through all of this and wanted us
out of afghanistan
but generals milli mattis mcmaster and
others
wanted us to stay in afghanistan as long
as it took meaning basically forever
now to this day they refuse to listen to
the american people who've been saying
no to these wars since about 2006.
it was always a pipe dream it was always
giving you know a stage to some of the
most odious people on earth the trump
administration doubled down on the
mistakes of the of the obama
administration after the president
abandoned what had been i think really
the first reasoned and sustainable
approach toward afghanistan in 2017 the
self-delusion really we're seeing an end
of that delusion now
delusion who's delusional people still
think they can win
they dragged their feet until trump's
last day in office and hated trump for
actually pushing what the american
people have been asking for since the
election of at least barack obama an end
to these wars
now as we saw over the past week our
military our political our diplomatic
our national security hierarchy is i'm
sorry it's just filled with a bunch of
people who shouldn't call themselves
experts they can't do logistics they
can't game out the obvious collapse of
order once our troops pulled out leaving
all these people in harm's way it's
heartbreaking
if the same humiliating bagram air base
scenes had played out under trump
the democrats and the media would have
crucified him
instead they kind of nod as biden and
his cabinet drone on mouthing
meaningless diplomatic gibberish
i'm not going to do it the way trump did
we're going to focus on
international rules of the road our
purpose is not
to contain china to hold it back to keep
it down
it is to uphold this rules-based order
that
china is posing a challenge to
but what we saw over the weekend in
afghanistan proved once again
that there never has been and never will
be such a thing as rules-based
international order
no one fights for a rules-based
international order no one dies for a
rules-based international order
we've all seen this before in 1928
germany france the united states and
many other countries signed the kellogg
brand pack now in that agreement they
pledged to renounce war as an instrument
of national policy in their relations
with one another it was basically a
pinky promise among girlfriends
there was no way to enforce it then of
course 11 years later nazi germany
invaded poland and the largest war in
human history began
so the peace is not kept by diplomats
meeting behind closed doors the peace is
not kept by solemn promises or beautiful
dreams
it's it never has been it never will be
there's only one way to have peace
you must be certain that the good guys
with guns are strong enough to defeat
the bad guys with guns that is it
now the biden team along with the rest
of our establishment is simply hapless
when it comes to dealing with the
taliban
president trump was right to insist that
we withdraw from afghanistan for the
simple reason that our national security
establishment was utterly incapable of
doing anything in that country beyond
wasting money and american lives
our secretary of defense should resign
immediately ditto for general milly
austin has been in over his head from
day one at the pentagon and general
milley has gotten almost nothing right
they should both
go on to tangle with some
more worthy adversaries maybe go be
professors on a u.s college campus or
something
the next secretary of defense should be
a civilian who will bring a new approach
to the pentagon he or she should clean
house and rid us of the incompetent
dolts who've made our military sadly
they deserve better
made them a laughingstock because of the
leadership that has poorly served them
the next chairman of the joint chiefs
should be someone who will tell our
political leaders the truth about the
military situation and who will never
never ever argue with members of
congress about whether america is a
racist nation
we need a top-down reform at the
pentagon
when biden finally emerged late today to
address the situation in afghanistan
well he correctly noted that it was long
since time for us to get out
but
he failed to explain how the withdrawal
the forces was so badly bungled i stand
squarely behind my decision
after 20 years
i've learned the hard
way that there was never a good time to
withdraw
u.s forces
that's why we're still there
we were clear-eyed about the risk
we plan for every contingency
i mean
every contingency really is that what we
saw over the weekend zero credibility
the next three years will be very
difficult for the united states
the ship of state is rudderless
our president is old and incompetent and
his advisors lack the political skills
necessary to manage the country in his
absence
inflation's going to soar crime rates
are going to continue to rise we'll
suffer further humiliations around the
world our enemies they're already
celebrating
we warned you about all of this last
year and now it's going to happen
but i'm telling you we have been here
before the carter years were one long
series of disasters
and they encourage many people here and
abroad to just give up on the united
states
well those people then were wrong
and next year the democrats will likely
lose at least one chamber of congress
and that's going to make things better
and then in 2024 we'll have a chance to
elect a real president who can actually
do the job who can defend american
interests and perhaps
bring about her renaissance
and that's the angle